you have everything you need to create
the life that you ultimately want right
now
[Music]
a lot of people will say you know our
greatest asset is time from a spiritual
minimalism perspective your greatest
asset is actually presence because you
can have all the time in the world but
if you're never present with that time
then is it really that valuable I think
we get in our heads about things like
purpose and meaning and we're sitting
around waiting to be struck by lightning
when it comes to your heart voice you
really only have one option you can't go
to me you can't go to any psychic or
therapist and they can sit you down and
say your purpose is to dot dot dot only
you know what that is but you have to
this episode is brought to you by Roca
five years ago light gave up all his
Earthly possessions save what he could
fit in a very small backpack and
proceeded to travel the world giving
talks on happiness mindfulness
inspiration meditation and writing a
book about what his experience taught
him called quite cheekily travel light
today we talk about how to prioritize
and cultivate inner happiness through
presence the importance of following
your curiosity and exactly specifically
how to do that and we also talk about
something he calls the freedom of
choicelessness to declutter your life
decisions I truly love this man he is a
wise and gentle expression of the human
form he's a natural and gifted teacher
and my sense is that this conversation
will leave you with more than a few
life-altering profundities to ponder and
practice if you have received value from
the content that we were work very hard
to freely share with you week in week
out it would mean a great deal if you
could take a brief moment to quickly hit
that subscribe button and with that I
thank you I appreciate you tuning in
today and uh please enjoy my
conversation with light Watkins
on your phone and on your tablet and in
your journals you compiled this book
which has brought us here today to
discuss
um travel light which I read and I love
I think it's great and I think this book
what's interesting about it is that on a
surface level it's sort of this book
about minimalism and how to kind of live
a little bit more lightly on your feet
um
but really beneath the surface
minimalism is just a device or like a a
lens or a vehicle for you to discuss
um bigger broader deeper questions about
how to pursue a more purposeful
meaningful
um life you know with more clarity and
and kind of conviction and peace and and
presence and and mindfulness so talk a
little bit about how you came up with
this idea for this book and and then you
know how do you and and really The Core
theme of it is this idea
of what minimalism really is by focusing
on this idea of spiritual minimalism as
opposed to the minimalism that we think
of which is like cleaning out your
closet and your relationship to all of
your material possessions right so as
you know from being on here three other
times mainly I'm talking about
meditation right my first book was about
happiness but really about cultivating
happiness inside using a practice of
Stillness second book Bliss more about
how to meditate Without Really Trying
last book inspiration but still
meditation themed this book
um travel light is as you say about
spiritual minimalism which is minimalism
from the inside out
and what that means is instead of
clearing out your closets and getting
rid of the old you know blender you
haven't used in three years and all of
that and creating space externally it's
about showing people how to cultivate
spaciousness internally
and as a byproduct of that you feel more
fulfilled just as a human and as a
byproduct of that you make better
choices for yourself for your life right
so
what a lot of people are doing is
they're engaged in what I call the
acquisitive approach to happiness or
fulfillment which is as soon as I get
the promotion as soon as I make my first
million as soon as I exit from my
company as soon as I get married as soon
as I have a child they have this idea
that I'm going to be happier or more
fulfilled than I am right now
and what spiritual minimalism says
is that actually
you're as happy right now as you're
going to be
when you achieve this thing in other
words achieving the thing is not going
to make you happier it's just going to
put you back in the state that you're in
right now
but having achieved something and
achievements in that sense is like an
amplifier of whatever you're feeling
right now so if you're feeling a sense
of misery right now and you achieve
something amazing the wave of Joy will
pass and you'll be back miserable again
but if you're happy right now if you
feel fulfilled right now and you
cultivate that then you can achieve
things and you'll still be fulfilled and
maybe even it'll inform you which goals
you go after having fulfillment now
will make you think okay well this
opportunity is not aligned with what I'm
feeling inside so I'm gonna even though
on the surface it looks glittery it
looks amazing but I'm going to pass that
one and I'm gonna go for this one that
doesn't look glittery but it is aligned
and you move in that direction and
usually that's where amazing things
start happening in your life
it is true uh and despite the fact that
that people like yourself are are
continually and constantly reminding us
of this fact the as they say in the
parlance of recovery like the
Persistence of this uh delusion is
astonishing because you're like yeah
yeah yeah but but you know when except
you don't understand like if I just get
this one thing or that you know
that um like sliver in the brain is very
difficult yeah to overcome and it's only
through direct experience with what you
just shared that you get a taste of the
true reality and on some level
it's a it's a conversation about East
versus West sort of because in the west
everything is about
um the external like bringing whatever's
that you whatever thing you don't have
that's outside of yourself into your
life as a path towards all the things
that you know we're seeking to
um engender in ourselves happiness
fulfillment purpose meaning all of that
kind of thing security Etc
um and we live in this city here where
we all know lots of very wealthy people
with fancy jobs and lots of
accomplishments who are not happy and
not grateful and not nice
and yet we still hold on to that idea
like yeah but it'll be different for me
in the same way we think
yeah I know everyone's gonna die but
maybe I'll figure out a way to not have
that happen to me and that's also one of
the reasons why we're so shocked when we
see celebrities behaving badly you know
like when Will Smith went up and slapped
Chris Rock everyone's shocked how could
he do that but you may see that you may
see a homeless person or somebody on the
street do the same thing you wouldn't
really think why are they doing that
it's pretty you know clear that they
don't have their basic needs met
externally and perhaps even internally
but we get shocked when someone has a
lot of money and they're behaving like
that because there's this still
indoctrination where we think to
ourselves well having money solves all
of your problems so why power Prestige
yeah why are you reacting
congratulations yeah and Will Smith
himself has said that being successful
doesn't heal your childhood childhood
trauma you know so there's still stuff
inside and that's the thing you can have
the most sparse beautiful looking
zen-like external environment but on the
inside you're still cluttered you're
holding on to toxic relationships you're
maybe holding on to a soul-sucking job
or a path in your life
and if if you're experiencing all that
clutter it prohibits you from being
present with this beautiful Zen space
that you happen to be in and it's kind
of like what Robert persick the guy who
wrote Zen and the Art of Motorcycle
Mason and said you the only Zen you're
going to find at the top of the mountain
this is in you bring up there with you
you know so it's like that every space
you enter every relationship you enter
any accomplishment you have you're going
to bring all the happiness that you're
going to get from that with you to the
relationship to the space to the
accomplishment right and then tying that
to minimalism and this sort of growing
Trend around minimalism and how we think
about it
uh
what's interesting is that
the true kind of way into that is to
begin with the outs like your inside
right like if you can get present if you
can resolve those childhood traumas or
um you know find a path to transcend
your anxiety or whatever it is inside of
you that's holding you back or is acting
as a barrier between you and purpose and
happiness Etc then
you have a sense of self that completely
reframes how you relate to that external
world and those material possessions Etc
don't carry the same weight or meaning
and become easier to relinquish or
um have without them owning you right so
to clear out your closet without doing
the other thing you're still left with
yourself and maybe that yearning or a
weird kind of emotional relationship to
the giving away of the stuff or the not
having it whereas
cleaning the inside
first makes that external process almost
uh
um
a natural extension of that Journey
exactly yeah you hold on to things a lot
less yeah sure
and everybody ultimately no matter what
you do in your life everybody ultimately
wants to be fulfilled right so
what is how do you get to be fulfilled
well that's where people you know have
different ideas some people think it's
because it's from accomplishments or
it's from money or it's from you know
some other external circumstance but
really
what brings fulfillment is living a
purposeful life right living I was
listening to this other podcast
interview and this guy was helping
people get out of prison and he said
there's no drug I've ever taken that
gives me the same high
as helping these these these inmates who
were innocent get freed from prison and
you know if you're being of service or
if you're raising a family and that's
what you've identified with as your
purpose or if you're doing something
else that's related to your heart then
you're experiencing some degree of
fulfillment that you would not be
experiencing otherwise and really the
only way to to know that is to have the
experience so then how do you lead a
purposeful life
well a lot of people are confused about
you know I don't know what my purpose is
I write about purpose a lot and I get a
lot of replies I don't I don't you know
I feel like I don't live that purposeful
life and so I say you have to follow
curiosity you know don't worry about
trying to find your purpose just follow
curiosity and your purpose will find you
well how do you follow your curiosity
well your curiosity is going to have you
doing things that are going to make you
look foolish probably and it's not going
to be practical and it's not going to
make a lot of sense to the people around
you so you have to be okay with that and
the only way to be okay with that is to
feel so
uh called by your purpose by by your
curiosity
that you're willing to do it anyway and
what stands in between you being able to
do that follow the Curiosity
with with with the fomo right fear of
other people's opinions fopo fear of
other people's opinions in full play
is you have to get rid of the stuff that
keeps you
Shackled to those opinions which is some
degree of
stress right because stress when you're
tired stress makes you tired stress
makes you anxious stress makes you
um
future thinking or you're you're focused
on a past regret it's hard to follow
your curiosity when you have those
things playing out in the back of your
awareness yeah I think it's it's it's
sort of like concentric rings and at the
core although this isn't directly a book
about meditation it is because all of
these things that that you're referring
to and talking about are a product of or
are cultivated and brought into
awareness and and into action by way of
the practice of meditation so when you
talk about curiosity as a path to
finding purpose
and and and and kind of the willingness
to get uncomfortable which is one of
your kind of like core pillars in the
book
um
to do things that you know might
embarrass you Etc
before you even get to that you have to
attune yourself to your curiosity and I
think most people and I know from my own
experience like my brain is just a
cacophony of signals and narratives and
confusion and fear and resentment and
and it's just all firing and going on is
like I don't know what my curiosity is
I've got like a symphony of insanity
going on right now so to even know what
I'm curious about or what I might be
interested in is a question that isn't
really
like
prioritized in our culture like hey what
are you curious about like it's not
something people ask you it's not
something you learn how to cultivate in
school I came to it much later in life
some people never feel like they have
the permission to you know indulge in
that or entertain it and indulge is the
wrong word because it's part of Being
Human it's not an indulgent it's a it's
a it's it's something we should all be
doing
but you have to get quiet with yourself
so you can hear yourself so then you
know when those you know percolating
kind of impulses around curiosity are
starting to emerge so
what is the process like how would you
like if if I just said that to you and I
was your student and you know your
meditation student like walk me through
how you would untangle that knot and you
know get me into a place where
I could hear the voice of my own innate
curiosity so that voice is in there we
usually refer to it as the still Small
Voice right those internal nudgings
those hunches saying hey maybe go left
instead of going right on your commute
today just see what happens or hey go
and compliment that person on their nice
shoes or hey
um
stay at home today and just read a book
you know these kinds of things and so
that voice is in there it's a still
small voice
and we had it when we were kids
everybody has it as a kid you know you
see kids they can play with a stick for
hours or they can just go out and
imagine things and make believe
and there's something that happens once
you start getting schooled is you get
indoctrinated to believe what success is
supposed to look like which is being
disciplined being responsible achieving
things getting married you know having a
good job
etc etc and then that becomes the
primary focus and then the voice of
curiosity or the still Small Voice gets
filed away in the extracurricular
activity
um folder where if you have enough time
when you're not being responsible and
you know working on your job or your
whatever then you can play around with
that on the weekends and actually it's
the opposite we should be prioritizing
that voice because that voice is keeping
us on track with whatever it is at our
purpose or our passion truly is in this
lifetime which no one can tell you what
that is no one can you can't go to
anyone you can't go to me you can't go
to any psychic or therapist and they can
sit you down and say your purpose is to
only you know what that is but you have
to get conversational in the language of
that internal voice now
coexisting with that voice you have the
voices of your teachers your parents
social conditioning Society culture the
news right all the media you consume
and
the only thing and I'm I know I'm
simplifying things a lot but the only
thing that determines how loud a
specific voice is is which one you
follow the most just like the parable of
the you know the two wolves and
whichever one you should eat the most
that's the one that's gonna be the
loudest so if you listen to the fear
Voice or the pain Voice or the trauma
voice and you've acted on that voice
more often than you've acted on the
still Small Voice or the voice of
intuition that voice is going to be
louder in your head and so what the
meditation does the Stillness practice
is
it will turn up the volume a little bit
on that still Small Voice enough for you
to hear it just enough to take a little
I call them hop of Faith forget about
the leap of faith it's too scary I get
it but take a hop of Faith just take one
tiny step in the direction of whatever
you're hearing or whatever you think
you're hearing and then you have to kind
of split test right you know and then
over split to over time from split
testing what you think is your heart
voice with all of the other voices maybe
a hundred times you'll start to become
more and more familiar with the feeling
tone that expansive feeling tone that
you always get when you follow your
heart voice when you take the little hop
of Faith you get a a feeling tone of
expansion as opposed to feeling
contracted you know like if something's
telling you
say something negative right now you
know curse somebody out it may very well
be justified in your mind you know
flicking somebody off in traffic
but does it make you feel expansive
afterward is the question
so now you know okay that's definitely
not my hard voice but if something says
okay forgive this person who you who
wronged you right no no two ways about
it they wronged you but you're going to
be the bigger person here
no one ever no one ever steps into the
role of being the bigger person and then
you like deeply regret that later on
right or going above and beyond going
the extra mile doing a an exceptional
job with something it's hard work and
you don't know how it's going to turn
out but it feels good going doing a
workout that you know is really taxing
on you but you always feel good after
having been pushed in that way and
that's how you know you're listening to
that that heart voice yeah I mean I
think there's certain actions
uh that are probably Universal to all
humans like you know extending Grace
forgiveness Etc gratitude and then
there's a subset
that's very particular to each
individual and this idea of these baby
hops I like because I think we get in
our heads about things like purpose and
meaning and all of that and we're
sitting around waiting to be struck by
lightning before we move forward we want
to know exactly what it is and all the
steps it's going to take to get to a
certain place but I think you're
absolutely correct and certainly it's
been my experience when I made a very
conscious decision to start heeding
those little you know voices that had
been lingering for a long time for no
other reason then it just felt like me
and over time it started to bring more
joy into my life and through a zillion
serendipitous situations has led me to
sitting with you today right and and I
love in the book you have your version
of that story and how you know all these
strange things that you could have never
predicted kind of came together to
um in you know in a conspiratorial way
to you know allow you to deep more
deeply invest in that in that heart song
and there's just something really
magical but also undeniably true about
it
and in the most simplest simplistic way
I would say
and you point this out in the book it's
about
changing your attention away from the
head and and towards the heart right
like how do you flick off the the
navigation system in your brain that's
responding to all of these voices and
the social conditioning and the baggage
Etc and and and really attune yourself
to you know what this thing right here
is trying to say that perhaps is a more
Divine navigation system
but in so many ways
because it defies rationality and logic
is hard for the Western mind to kind of
get behind yeah I'll give you an example
for my personal life so I was teaching
meditation this is years ago I was
teaching meditation in New York City
and um and I'm constantly at that time
I'm constantly thinking how can I teach
more people how to meditate
so late at night after one of my
trainings I'm walking back to my
apartment I'm walking through Union
Square
and something tells me to go and get a
Rubik's Cube from Barnes and Noble which
is at the North End of Union Square and
learn how to solve it
you know it's just most random thought
and so at that point in my life I have
such a strong relationship with my heart
voice that I I try not to question it so
I just went to Barnes and Noble they
were going to close in like 10 minutes
and I knew where the toy section was on
the second floor so I went there and I
found they had one Rubik's Cube left so
I got the Rubik's Cube
and I paid for it and then got back to
my Airbnb that I was staying in and on
the way there I called up a buddy of
mine who you know he's one of my close
friends who talk often and I told him
that I'm gonna learn how to solve the
Rubik's Cube and then he did what
Society does which is he starts telling
what are you talking about you have
you're a grown ass man you don't have
time to play in Rubik's Cubes you have
to be figuring out how to Market your
business and I said well you know I I
have to I have to do this it's just you
know something I feel like I need to do
so I go online and I figure out how to
solve a Rubik's Cube which I never never
even investigated before turns out
there's an algorithm to solving a
Rubik's Cube I used to think you needed
to be a genius it's on Rubik's Cube but
you just have to memorize these series
of steps so I started working through
the series of steps couple days later I
learned how to solve a Rubik's Cube
which is a pretty incredible thing to do
on a New York Subway to sit there and
solve a Rubik's Cube everyone's like
gawking at you yeah
but anyway what I learned from that
experience
was the way you solve for Rubik's Cube
is very similar to the way meditation
works you solve it in rows so the bottom
row is sort of like the base you solve
that first then the middle row then the
top row and then the whole thing solves
and I'm thinking to myself wow this is
just like how meditation Works where you
you solve the base of rest first and
then from that you get digestion back
online you get immunity back online you
get reproduction back online and then
everything comes back into balance so
now I'm just captivated by this
comparison that I never would have known
otherwise and I decide I'm going to make
a video about this and I'm gonna put it
out on this on this new website called
YouTube and because this is you know
back when YouTube had first started so I
make this video in my living room in Los
Angeles once I get back from my trip
and it goes viral
and then all these people start reaching
out to me to learn how to meditate and
that was at a moment in time where you
were kind of at a Crossroads with your
with like the business of your yeah I'm
looking for ways to teach more people
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's like it's
like my heart was was leading me to the
solution just by making me curious about
these other things and it came up with a
solution that was even more eloquent
than what I was thinking before which is
you know should I run Google ads or you
know what should I do and it was like no
do this beautiful thing that can be
unique to you and that's the power of
following that Curiosity but you're
right you have to you have to be able to
hear it first and I I you know I've been
meditating for many years at that point
and I attribute that for allowing me to
be able to hear that voice a little bit
well and and you you had kind of
practice this uh Habit of of investing
in your curiosity so much that it has
it's become reflexive right it's just
like anything else it's it's the inner
gym right like this is just one thing
and and part of of like the whole
getting comfortable with the
uncomfortable people think about that in
terms of like Fitness or whatever you
got to suffer Etc but the discomfort in
that context is trusting when there's no
reason to trust for any purpose
whatsoever and still kind of like
pulling that thread and following that
Muse and and and making a conscious
decision that oh this is this is my
curiosity I'm somebody who follows my
curiosity we're going to Barnes Noble
and we're getting this thing right and
you have to decide am I going to be more
loyal to other people's opinions because
that's really what's stopping us is the
potential of looking silly or you know
wasting time which then leads to people
questioning what were you doing with
your time oh I was playing with a
Rubik's Cube oh that's why you're a
failure you know that's what plays out
in our mind versus being loyal to our
heart and just trusting that whatever
we're hearing
is going to help us to move towards our
path yeah purpose yeah so we become lit
we start living a more purposeful life
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuilt
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
the other like wisdom nugget that I get
out of what you just shared is is is
this idea that
um these things are subtle like they're
not
you know setting aside the lightning
bolt they don't come pre-packaged with
like here's your path or this is your
next goal they're like tiny lit it's
like the yeah like I'm going to turn
left here instead of turning right
meaningless tiny little details of life
that I guess on some level are kind of
analogous to
Atomic habits like they're just tiny
little things that in and of themselves
are seemingly meaningless but
they're they're like minuscule
breadcrumbs right and you're on some
kind of like you know treasure hunt yeah
and that's why I say in the book one of
the principles is that you have to you
have to treat life like there are no
throwaway moments
so every little thing go to Barnes Noble
get a Rubik's Cube it wasn't easy to
learn how to solve Rubik's Cube it took
a lot of time and practice Yeah right so
when you are moving towards your path a
lot of people think oh that's gonna
that's where my life is Gonna Get Easier
actually that's when your life becomes a
lot more challenging because you're
introducing resistance that on the
surface looks unnecessary
but as you continue moving through that
process you're learning things you're
expanding your perceptual Acuity in ways
that are outfitting you for whatever
your path is going to include next and
if you hadn't gone through that
experience then you would not be
prepared to do the things that you
ultimately Envision yourself doing and I
think that's something we under
appreciate right and it also allows you
to frame everything that happens as an
opportunity right rather than you know
label it as positive or negative right
and and I'm reminded of the story I
think you told the story last time but
it's it's kind of like your your male
model origin story and you're going to
Paris and the flight keeps getting
canceled but you're getting these 500
vouchers each time and those are kind of
mundane annoying moments but maybe
positive because you're actually
profiting off of it
um but when you finally arrive in Paris
and you know kind of enter this agency
there's this assembly of people that
happen to be there when you were there
that lead you on this whole path that
you know kind of created a life for you
for a certain amount of time that had
you gotten on that original flight and
it wasn't overbooked Etc maybe those
people wouldn't have been there it would
have been a whole different thing so
there are no mundane moments there are
no real like that was those setbacks in
not getting to Paris in the manner in
which you would have preferred
um
could be seen as a as problematic but
actually it was this you know amazing
opportunity right that led you in a way
that you couldn't have led yourself yeah
and I'll share another one
um just because I think it's it's a good
it's good to reflect also on the
opposite when something seemingly bad
happens right which everyone on the
surface would say yeah that's not a
great situation which is you know I was
teaching yoga back in the day and I was
living in West Hollywood and my my yoga
class was at Crunch Gym which was in
Sunset Boulevard Sunset Plaza so my
commute was literally half a mile down
Fountain Avenue right and I had
everything timed out I would leave my
apartment
it would take me probably five minutes
to get to the gym
and except this morning I go to Fountain
and there's all this bumper-to-bumper
traffic so like any good Los Angeles
driver I zigzag through alleys down to
Santa Monica Boulevard to see if I can
go that direction and same thing it was
full of bumpers usually worse yeah Santa
Monica so I'm inching along and I didn't
give myself more than about 10 minutes
to get to this class and I have this
thing about being punctual so now I'm
getting all you know anxious and trying
to breathe through it and finally I just
surrender to it and then I get to
Fairfax which is where if there was an
obstruction it would have probably been
it this was the major intersection so
I'm looking for construction I'm
wondering was the president in town is
there an accident was there some crazy
you know person in the middle of the
street holding up traffic and there was
nothing there was nothing the traffic
just cleared up and then I'm even more
upset because now I have nothing to
blame it on and it's just that there was
a lot of traffic which as we know living
in Los Angeles you can't really blame
the traffic because everybody knows
there's traffic and now I'm about 10
minutes late to this class
that I'm teaching
and I walk in to the class and
everyone's in the back of the room and I
feel this crunching under my flip-flops
and I look down and there's like a
million shards of glass all over the
floor and I look up
and
so that particular room has a wall of
mirrors
in the front and I would have been
sitting right in the middle of that wall
and right in the middle of the wall
there's an empty space where a mirror
was supposed to be apparently right at
the top of the hour
that mirror that mirror panel which is
about nine feet tall and about maybe
four feet wide dislodged and Came
Crashing Down
so it turns out that Phantom traffic jam
saved your life that I surrendered to
yeah saved me from having a very unlucky
start to my day yeah you know and that's
that's the opposite side of it too just
when you and I talk about this the
freedom of choicelessness when you don't
have an option you tried everything you
could do you left on time you hit
traffic on one street okay let me go to
the other Street hit traffic on that
street you're giving a gift of
choicelessness which means that you are
being navigated now
and instead of getting all anxious and
out of the present moment just surrender
to it understand that it's it's sparing
you from something that's worse than
that traffic
that's so hard that's minimalism that's
spiritual minimalism though you know
because otherwise we're holding on to oh
what could Coulda should have would have
been happening right now which is really
just future tripping and and predicting
something that actually we have no idea
whether that's actually you may never
know yeah I got lucky in that situation
because I got to see you know pretty
obviously what what would have happened
otherwise but you may never know
and you don't know the timeline either
no of how these things assemble to guide
you in a certain way and there really
are no no small moments no no no minor
things because it is those tiny little
nudges one way or the other that you
know have this Butterfly Effect yeah but
you look at okay let's run the opposite
experiment let's say I I was just it's
better to be anxious the whole time well
what does anxiety do
it Yanks you out of the present moment
it makes you not present and
you know a lot of people will say you
know our greatest asset is time
right if I can get more time buy my time
back whatever then that's going to be
better than than not having my time but
I would argue from a spiritual
minimalism perspective that your
greatest asset is actually presence
because you can have all the time in the
world but if you're never present
with that free time then is it really
that valuable right versus not having as
much time but being fully present and
then if you're present is kind of like
one of those Magic Eye puzzles you know
where you look at it and it just looks
like a bunch of chaos and you soften
your gaze and then eventually an image
starts to appear from the chaos right
like that when you're present
and you're not anxious and you're just
kind of relaxed
you get you start to see and experience
opportunities and insights and
epiphanies that you would otherwise Miss
because you're so locked into what's not
happening or something that you're
regretting from the past and that's the
value of present moment awareness and
that can that can
um
help you in your relationships like what
relationship does not benefit from both
people being more present right right
and a lot of us are saying okay well as
soon as they're present I'm going to be
present it's not how it works you get
what you give and that talk about that
and that's a principle yeah you give
what you want to receive so if you want
more love you have to be more loving in
order to nurture that within the
relationship if you want more presence
you have to be more present but light I
want to wait until they give it to me
first and then I'll Grant it right like
it's run that experiment and see how it
works out for you I know and then come
back and talk to me it is really true uh
you mentioned earlier this idea of of
split testing like split testing your
internal voice so walk me through an
example of what that might look like
because I think that's instructive
for somebody who's kind of playing
around with this notion for maybe the
first time
so for people who are familiar with
internet marketing
that's what makes a good internet
marketer they split test things so they
run an ad
and they run it they run a different ad
but with a different headline and
they'll see which one performs better
and then they'll change the color on one
and keep the color the same on the other
and I'll see which one performs better
and so through doing all of those
experiments they'll eventually arrive at
the most optimized ad for whatever the
purpose is of that ad and like that with
split testing we can do that with our
internal voices you have the voice that
you think is your heart voice and you
have imitator voices and some of those
imitator voices are really
voices of your ego you know telling you
um to follow a certain path which may
seem altruistic but if you really are
honest with yourself it's really because
you think it's going to make you look
better in the eyes of someone else right
fine follow it follow it and see what
happens see how it makes you feel and
then go and do the opposite you know
it's kind of like that that Seinfeld
episode where George constanza decides
I'm going to just do the he says I'm not
having any any luck at work with women
with anything and Jerry says well just
start doing the opposite of what you
would normally do yeah if what you're
doing now is getting you the worst
results yeah you can't lose anything by
doing the opposite and he starts doing
that and he starts being completely
honest with the women that he's dating
he goes to the job interview he he you
know which is at the Yankees or
something he says he starts talking crap
about how the Yankees is running are
running the organization and that he
gets hired he gets these beautiful women
and he starts doing he starts getting
the opposite of what he was getting
before and you know that's what's so
great about life experience is whether
you're skeptical about these kinds of
Concepts or whether you buy into them
your experience is giving you the
results
right that you're getting and if those
results feel fulfilling to you then
great keep doing more of that but if
they're not regardless of what you
believe or think should be happening you
kind of have to do the opposite in order
to to really understand whether or not
what you've been doing is the thing to
do and so that's what split testing
basically means is you can still keep
following that voice that you've been
following but try doing the opposite a
few times and just see just see what
happens don't take my word for it to see
what happens in uh in 12-step they call
contrary action you know it's like hey
smart guy you think you know it all like
your best thinking land as you hear like
how smart are you you know maybe not
keep I know you want to do that thing
but you know that thing actually you
know is why you're here and like go take
contrary action do the thing that feels
very uncomfortable and maybe doesn't
feel right
because
you're not used to flexing it in that
way or you've just dug this neural
Groove and convinced yourself that you
know what's best and it's only through
you know that's a I guess a different
way of of thinking about split testing
to try to you know determine if maybe
all these other people are saying I
shouldn't do that thing that I want to
do like what happens if I take their
advice or their Collective wisdom and
act on that and then just objectively
kind of note what transpires as a result
so I had to experience many years ago
where I was I used to drive a Fiat right
I'm six foot three and I used to drive a
two-door Fiat how do I mean there's that
would be a back story there I just you
know I was at a place where I was
teaching yoga I didn't have a whole lot
of money and uh and that was really the
only car I could afford at the time
and I would go to the coin operated car
wash and I remember one day washing my
car and trying to get the whole thing
clean before the three minutes was up
and this beautiful matte black Ferrari
was in the next stall and I'm thinking
to my I'm in my head I'm like man this
is so emasculating here I am grown ass
man with this little Fiat and this guy
whatever he's doing has this Ferrari and
what am I doing wrong with my life again
I'm teaching people you know to find
happiness inside but I'm not perfect
right I'm still going through my own
struggles and anyways we both pull out
at the same time to the drying station
and I'm drying my car with my little
reusable yellow you know uh towel and
he's got these really beautiful white
towels like something you get at the
Four Seasons and he's trying his Ferrari
this is big Burly guy and I'm still like
in my head around you know why do I have
a Fiat he's got a Ferrari and this is
embarrassing blah blah and then I pull
out my tire polish and I start spraying
my tires and I look over and he doesn't
have any Tire polish and then something
says to me
you know you admire his car so much go
and offer him some Tire polish so I went
over there and I said hey you have such
a beautiful car
and uh it'll be a shame for you to go
back on the road without polishing up
your tires and I said I would love to
let you use my tire polish and he takes
it he graciously received it he shines
up his tires and I go back to my Fiat
and I'm still drying it off and then he
does something really interesting he
comes back to the Fiat with his white
towels and he starts spraying my tires
and Shining up my tires and I'm
initially I was thinking let me stop him
from doing that because I mean he
doesn't have to do that and but I
decided to just receive it in the same
way that he received it you know with
such Grace
and of course we started a conversation
and he told me his whole back story he's
you know he was an immigrant and he
started off working at a car wash and
then he worked his way up to owning a
Ferrari dealership and
um and then he ended up telling me to
come and teach his his employees
meditation
and you suck those little moments you
know every amazing experience that we
have we go back far enough there was a
moment where
something told us to dot dot dot which
is that hop of faith you know it doesn't
have to be a huge thing right just go
with what that voice is telling you to
do my voice at that time was saying go
and offer him which was an expansive
feeling for me right it wasn't like my
life purpose to go and get people Tire
polish but just in that moment but then
it led to these beautiful other
experiences and and that's really where
that's the gateway to what could
theoretically be your purpose and you
can't act on that voice uh or you can't
hear that voice let alone act on it
unless you are presence but that's how
you can turn up the volume on your
presence as well is by taking acting on
in those little moments that would
otherwise be dismissal I'm not going to
do that that's crazy you know how many
times do we say that to ourselves that's
crazy yeah I'm not going to do that yeah
I'm not going to compliment them because
they're gonna think I'm weird and blah
blah
you know you have to say yes to those
things if you want to turn up the volume
that's a great story
um some of these words get really
conflated with each other and I think
they confuse a lot of people when we
start talking about fulfillment and
purpose and curia even curiosity and
presence Etc
um and and one of the things you talk
about in the book is
you know by
cultivating this curiosity and acting on
it you you start to get a clearer kind
of picture for you know what your
purpose might be eventually but then you
weave in this idea of having a value set
or or trying to kind of calibrate these
decisions that you're making and how
you're acting on your heart in
conjunction with you know your values so
how does that how can you explain that
so it feels like it makes sense and we
have some clarity about what all these
words actually mean okay so
we in our society we oftentimes
put a lot of value on having multiple
options
when actually when it comes to your
heart voice you really only have one
option
which means that there's one option that
is most aligned with
what you feel inside and everything else
may be good may be great on paper but it
doesn't quite feel aligned right for
instance
I there was a moment back in 2006 when I
got into real estate we all know what
happened in two late 2006 2007. yeah I
remember sitting at the table with my
realtor who I didn't really trust he was
a nice guy but I didn't really trust he
was giving me the best advice he was
giving me self-serving advice he made a
lot of money off of those transactions
but I remember sitting at the table
everything in my heart was saying don't
whatever you do
don't sign these papers right but I was
thinking okay
I'm going to be able to flip these
properties because everybody and their
mother was flipping houses at the time
in Los Angeles
I can do a lot of good with this money
so I tried to make it altruistic but
really if I'm being honest with myself I
was really just being greedy and I was
going against my heart voice in that
moment but on paper anybody would have
looked at and go oh this is a great
great deal so I went through with it
ended up losing my shirt
and my pants and everything else my
socks and I came very close to filing
for bankruptcy over the next few years
and simultaneously I had this this
desire to go to India with my meditation
teacher and learn how to become a
meditation teacher
and during that time between the real
estate bubble bursting and going to
India
I also got an email from the Department
of Justice victim notification unit
saying that I was the victim of a Ponzi
scheme so one of the ways I was able to
buy the property was because I've been
in quotes investing in this foreign
currency exchange company and it looked
like it was going really well this is
before Bernie Madoff came to light so
turns out it was a Ponzi scheme and they
were just in they would create they were
basically manufacturing these gains
every week sending us these PDF
statements and I was thinking I you know
I was thinking I was freaking Warren
Buffett like I was the smartest person
on earth wow but turns out it was all
just make believe I lost everything
and um
and so that exacerbated the whole
bankruptcy conversation but
during that process I was getting these
credit card offers in the mail and
balanced transfer offers in the mail
because I was in real estate
and that allowed me to go to India
because I needed to come up with
fourteen thousand dollars within like a
week to be able to pay for this trip so
all that to say even though on paper it
looked like some bad things were
happening
I still was able to sort of course
correct by following through on this
heart voice which was saying go to India
it didn't say this is how you're going
to pay for India just says go to India
right and everything in my heart was
like okay that's where I'm gonna go I
had no money I was going through these
bankruptcy conversations but at the same
time I was getting these offers in the
mail because I hadn't filed bankruptcy
yet right and you were playing in kind
of a big field where a lot of money was
getting exchanged so it just rang some
Bells somewhere in some banks saying
this guy should you know let's let's get
this guy a credit card and when I got it
yeah even though I would never do
something like that you know if I was
solving because it just looks okay yeah
it's interest-free for 18 months but
then it's gonna go up to like some crazy
loan shark level of Interest make your
whole problem worse when I got it I knew
that this was the answer this was what I
was supposed to use and it was a
different feeling tone from sitting at
the table about the sign the paperwork
it was more expansive because I'm
thinking now about the possibility of
really truly helping people by learning
how to teach meditation so it wasn't
about being a real estate Mogul which I
had no passion for but I was trying to
trying to convince myself that I was
passionate about it right right right
right right I I'm trying to kind of
marinate in the lived experience of you
sitting there about to sign these papers
and having this Instinct that it wasn't
the right thing and trying to
differentiate that fear which was a fear
of self-preservation or you know a sort
of a sense of yourself that was being
animated from being out of alignment
versus
uh just that discomfort of suddenly
stepping into something new that's
unfamiliar like it could have been like
a little Ripple different and it's just
like well I'm afraid because I've never
done this before and I'm biting off a
lot if I sign this but I know that this
is the right path for me like those are
two very different energies that show up
in a way that can feel somewhat similar
unless you're cultivating an adequate
amount of self-awareness to
differentiate the two yeah and really it
just comes down to just to give it a
definition aligned or not aligned like I
didn't feel a line at the real estate
table but it did feel aligned to use
that money to go to India and then I
still either in both cases I had no idea
how it was going to turn out right but
there was a tangible feeling tone of
expansion when I got that offer and I
used it to buy my ticket and then within
a month of coming back from India I was
able to pay off the whole thing and you
know if everything kind of worked doubt
from there right but that's why it's
called a leap of faith it's because it's
not you're not going to know how it's
going to turn out and both feet have to
leave the ground and you have to be
scared as hell in the process yeah and
then the net appears it's just not going
to appear if you have one toe in on the
ground and you know the other foot in
the air yeah that's the thing
um but you also were quick to note that
you know a leap of faith isn't one thing
it's a lifestyle and when you see people
who make these dramatic leaps of Faith
they're generally backed up with all
kinds of baby hops behind it that are
invisible that you didn't see because
they're not dramatic so in the
experience of that person who made that
leap of faith there was some kind of you
know evidentiary backup you know based
upon all these smaller leaps that took
place prior to that yeah and same thing
with me people may get this book and oh
this guy lives out of a backpack I
didn't just wake up one day and decide
I'm gonna live in a backpack it started
with me on the road all the time and
then experimenting with what I needed
right so I would put everything into my
carry-on bag and see if I could get
through the two-week trip or whatever it
was just from the carry-on bag and then
I did that probably dozens of times and
then I decided okay I'm gonna experiment
with this nomadic minimalism thing and
see if I can pull it off and that's when
I got rid of everything and got rid of
the apartment and moved into the
carry-on bag and then I downsized from
that to a 40 liter backpack and then a
year later I downsized to a day pack and
so it was a progress it was a process
that started probably three or four
years prior to that and even if you want
to really go further back people say you
know when did you become a minimalist I
became a minimalist when I started
taking my meditation practice seriously
because that's what cultivated the
internal spaciousness for me to even
entertain the idea of letting go of this
conventional life and trying out this
thing that I had no idea how it was
going to turn out
yeah that's interesting
um
you talk about
um you kind of walk through the process
of like letting go of all your
belongings and giving away things and
even your brother had gifted you a Rolex
and you like gave it back to him I was
curious about like how he received that
like did he feel is he still wearing it
um do you want it back uh but
um
also uh the story around
the the
uh the four thousand dollars that um
was the only money that you had in the
bank
[Music]
and you giving it to to a buddy of yours
and saying if I don't finish my book by
this date you can cash it and use it for
whatever you want yeah so it was my
first book that I was writing and I had
no idea what I was doing and um I went
online to try to find Freelancers to
help me edit the book I just had this
idea that I wanted to get out into the
world
and
it took me about three and a half years
to get that book out but three years
into it
I was so just sick and tired of being
sick and tired of thinking about this
book and starting and stopping and
starting and stopping and I realized
that I just needed something more I
needed to put some skin in the game more
so than I had already done
so
I reached out to my friend
um and I said hey
I'm trying to finish writing this book I
put myself on a deadline of you know I'm
gonna get this thing published three
months from now
so I need to finish the manuscript by
such and such date
and I said to hold myself accountable
I'm writing you this check
for four thousand dollars and if I do
not
achieve my Milestone of finishing the
manuscript by such and such date you are
obligated to
take this money and use it for anything
that has nothing to do with me and I had
a whole little contract and everything
and I signed it and had him sign it and
then after that you know I had all the
Time in the World to finish this book
amazing how that works freed up all my
time right because there was no way I
was gonna I couldn't afford to lose that
money it was all the money I had it at
the time and and sure enough I got it
through and that's that taught me
something it taught me that discipline
is not really about having the time or
the willpower it's really about honesty
are you being honest enough with
yourself right for instance if you're
saying to yourself
I'm gonna wake up at six in the morning
and then I'm gonna write before I go to
work or I'm gonna write after I go to
work but you've never done that before
you're probably not going to do it on a
consistent enough basis to see the thing
through to the end so you may have to
move things around and you may have to
figure out how can I integrate the
writing kind of like what James Clear
talks about habit stacking how can I do
it on top of something else that I'm
already doing and and that way you're
more
um you're going to be a lot more
uh likely to make that time because
you're already doing something else that
is aligned with it right for instance me
wanting to work out on a consistent
basis well I'm going to this gym that's
three miles away which requires me to
dress up get in the car blah blah blah
so I paid a little more money to go to a
gym around the corner that I could walk
to and then I started going every day
because I had to put myself more closer
in proximity to that and these are
questions we can all ask ourselves if
I'm trying to stop eating sugar but I
have a bunch of sugar in my pantry a
bunch of Oreos and nachos and all kinds
of stuff then I'm probably going to find
myself in that pantry right you know
talking myself into why I need to have
this Oreo right now but if I get rid of
all of that I have no choice and if I
put carrots or whatever fruit in my
refrigerator now that's the only option
I have and that's how I'm gonna honor my
Integrity is by
um putting myself in the best possible
position to be loyal to whatever has
been happening in the past so that in a
ended up working out with the book and
that's how I got the inner gem published
and that's led to everything that's
followed yeah but again it was hard it
wasn't easy no I'm sure that wasn't fun
it was hard and that's the thing were
you cursing yourself I can't believe I
did that why did I do yeah we think that
was a good idea but I at the same time I
it was effective and I had to I had to
admit that it was effective and so now
when I'm trying to do stuff like I
wanted to I've been trying to learn
Spanish right since I've been living in
Mexico
and I
I bet a friend of mine that you know I
was going to be able to be to be able to
speak Tarzan Spanish by the end of or
the beginning of this past year I bet
him ten thousand dollars I had no
intention of parting ways with ten
thousand dollars but that got me taking
this course and you know just learning
all the basic things that I needed to
learn in order to navigate
um in Spanish enough to be able to have
basic interactions with people and I
wouldn't have done that otherwise I know
that so did he have to pay you ten
thousand dollars
right right right yeah
um yeah the kind of reversing the
incentive structure a little bit to
create behavioral change I I think it's
Tim Ferriss who has a spin on that he
had some idea about
um a relationship with a gym where if
you don't show up or you miss your
training session or whatever every time
you do that you give them money and the
donation is made to an organization that
you load Yeah Tim Ferriss has donated to
the Maga exactly in your name right
um another I don't know if it's Tim
Ferriss uh maybe I heard it on his
podcast though but there's this idea
um around uh a decision tree around how
to say yes like when to say yes to
things and when to say no which is kind
of at the that's sort of the the
practical Crux of what we're talking
about right like how are you allocating
your attention well you have to say no
to things and you say yes to things and
that idea that he was speaking of has to
do with like the hell yes right you know
when it's a hell yes and you know you're
going to do it but when you're like yeah
I can kind of rationalize maybe yeah
there's good reasons for me to do like
that's when you know it's a no right but
you haven't added kind of Ripple on top
of this it's like the hell yes is easy
right like if it's a hell yes of course
you're gonna do it right but the real
trick is developing the ability to say
yes when it's what you call a scary yes
yeah yeah and the scary yes those are
the things that are going to push you
past your comfort zone
and you know it could be a simple simple
things like taking uh uh going to a cold
plunge right
I personally don't love the idea of
doing a cold plunge but
you know there's all these health
benefits around that and that's just an
example of you know how we can
benefit from doing something that you
know you don't really want to do like
even going to the gym or going for a run
like people don't even David Goggins
talks about that he stares at his shoes
for 30 minutes you know trying to talk
himself out of it but then eventually he
has to say yes to that because that's
what he's committed to doing and that's
what I consider to be a scary yes if you
are someone who is co-dependent in a
relationship the idea of being on your
own
could qualify as a scary yes I'm going
to say yes to that I'm going to get out
of this thing that's not serving me for
whatever reason and I'm going to be on
my own for however long that lasts right
that's a scary yes or
if you're on your own and you've been
out doing just the single thing being in
a relationship where someone is actually
depending on you someone's holding you
accountable to your word that could be a
scary yes so it's always different for
different people but
that's where you're going to be able to
grow and stretch into your potential
much more than just you know doing the
hell yes which is easy to do because
it's obvious versus
um you know
thinking that you're going to wake up
one day and just rise to this level of
potential that you've never quite
practiced or that you're going to feel
like doing the thing that that you never
feel like doing right that suddenly
you're going to be struck with a level
of motivation to get over the hump
rather than developing the habit of just
getting into action irrespective of your
mood around it yeah and one of my
biggest scary yeses personally was seven
years ago two days ago seven years ago
June 6 of 2016
I hit send on the first
of what became a seven year plus
commitment of the daily dose of
inspiration email so that's two thousand
five hundred and fifty five emails done
that every day every day without missing
a day you know and that required not
just saying yes to that but also saying
no to a lot of invitations saying no to
sleeping in in the morning saying no to
staying up late at night you know and
just so many thousands of knows in order
to keep honoring that yes and that's
again what makes a a scary yes scary is
that you have to prioritize it and you
have to say no to a lot of things that
look like a lot of fun and you know can
lead to some pretty cool experiences but
that's what requires to be on your
purpose is you have to you want to
commit to what your heart is telling you
to do and that's one of the things that
makes it really really scary because I
didn't think I'd be doing it for this
long but you know it's still happening
and I'm still having to say yes to it
every day yeah you know I've thought
countless times about quitting yeah
like hey I did enough nobody's gonna say
boo about it yeah like it's on you but
it's about me and me it's my
relationship with me it's about it's not
really about anybody else how long is
the backpack thing been going on five
years five years five years five years
yeah
so I've realized I have this period
around my birthday which is May 30th
where I make these
big I say I I say a yes to something
that's scary and uh so the nomadic thing
was one and the daily dose thing was one
starting the shine movement was one I
did that the first one of those was like
June the second or something like that
so there's been a few things like that
that have happened around that time and
I see birthdays like that I'm not really
that into birthdays I just turned 50 in
fact this past May 30th you look amazing
for fifth Perfect Skin that's incredible
it's all that meditation man and uh and
even though that's a Monumental you know
Milestone which I I definitely
um acknowledge but it's really more
about okay what can I do this year
that's gonna that's gonna commit me even
more to my purpose and so those are the
kinds of questions so what is that like
if you so we're not that far away from
May 30. yeah we just spat it hasn't
occurred to me yet and that's the other
thing I'm not trying to come up with the
answer I'm just facilitating the
question the answer will come
and when it comes it's my job to say yes
to it
and without shaming myself and all of
that so
um so right now what I'm getting is to
scale back a little bit and to focus
your energy on on on you know on things
a little bit more instead of being a
little bit spread out I love it how I
feel you're gonna scale back the guy who
lives out of a backpack right yeah he's
thinking he needs to scale back yeah
yeah
um I love how in the book you kind of
thread like the the whole the book kind
of you know periodically throughout the
book you return to the backpack and like
here's what's in it here's why here's
how I do it
um and you've really got this down to a
pretty reductionist science and I can't
help but think while I'm reading this
um I'm comparing you know my travel
habits to years and I have this ongoing
frustration with myself because I over
pack every time
and I generally rationalize it because
typically I'll bring my hard case with
my podcast gear wherever I go just in
case like just in case you know I might
meet that person and the opportunity
will arise to do a podcast so I bring my
whole thing
and sometimes that happens
um not always it just happened in
Australia so I'm glad that I brought it
with me but that means I'm checking no
matter what right so there's no reason
to have the carryout the small carry-on
I might as well just bring the bigger
suitcase and half packet and then as I'm
half packing it I'm like well if it
rains or if it's cold you know like and
then I end up with all this junk I'm
hauling around all over the place and
then when I get to my location I end up
wearing like
two T-shirts same thing like the one
pair of pants and that's it and I I
figure out like oh I can wash these here
and I never really unpack my bag and
then I keep it and I do it again and I
do it again yeah the big game changer
for me was learning or teaching myself
how to hand wash my clothes yeah you go
through that in the book and I go I
teach people how to do it in the book
and then I got rid of like 70 of my
wardrobe and just had you know three
pairs of underwear a few t-shirts you
know one pair of pants etc etc and the
idea is not to you know I'm not hand
washing my clothes every night because
like in my Airbnb I have a washer and
dryer so I'm using that and you can kind
of source where you're gonna stay based
on washer dryer access yeah but it helps
a lot but if it doesn't have that it's
not a deal breaker it's like okay I can
hand wash my clothes I've done it
hundreds of times at this point and it's
actually a lot more efficient than
people think and then ultimately you
turn those kinds of things into a
meditation you turn the packing into a
meditation you turn the hand washing of
clothes into a meditation like we talk
about walking in the book you turn that
into them so everything essentially
becomes meditative and so it's not like
a hassle because it's just an extension
of that process as keeping you anchored
in the present moment and again that's
where all the opportunities are being
sourced that are beneficial and and and
and and
relevant to your heart is from that
present moment awareness but
yeah I mean it's and I'm also not
encouraging people to live from a
backpack either right but
everybody has their version of that
right there's something that in you
that's been nagging you about hey you
know moving this direction just explore
this be curious about that
and it it would require as much
faith in yourself as moving into a
backpack required for me it hasn't been
easy right it's definitely
um challenges in a lot of ways but and I
do a podcast from my backpack yeah and I
do Keynotes talks and I do panel
discussions and I go on dates and I go
hiking and I go on hot air balloons and
all the things from whatever I have in
my backpack but I've had to make some
very
big choices in terms of okay you know
I'm I can't have this quality of mic I
have to have this quality of my if I
want to keep doing this lifestyle
and so yeah you have to make these
decisions but when things change
you you upgrade the decision and that
could all change I could stop living
from the backpack you know next week I
don't know if I get the call to do that
then I'll do that
but uh but yeah we all have that we all
have a version of that and so the whole
message of the book is find your version
of that and just start moving in that
direction just see what happens don't
have any don't be attached to any
outcome just be in the process of it all
and you may surprise yourself by how
amazing things turn out and when you go
back it's going to start with something
told me too dot
I think with the backpack thing and I in
thinking about your relationship to it
it is a it is about
non-attachment in that it's about not
attaching to to your material belongings
but it's also about not attaching to how
long you're going to do it or what it
means and not identifying as some kind
of martyr in doing it like you're doing
it to learn something at some point you
will have learned everything there is to
learn about that and and and you will
return to some different variation of
that that makes sense for you at that
moment one of my pre-sale
um campaigns for this book is I'm doing
a drawing where I'm giving away the
backpack I'm giving away my meditation
shawl I'm giving away my Mala beads like
basically all the things I've been
carrying with me I'm going to give it
away to some person who enters the
drawing just by purchasing the book and
and showing proof of purchase and so
maybe after that something you know
different will happen right right well
it's either you can fill it with a
different version of the same thing or
it'll be that May 30th kind of uh
question will get answered in a new and
different way yeah yeah that's right but
you know it's it's all exciting that's
the thing and the thing that's changed
for me is I stopped trying to figure out
what this means what's going to happen
and just kind of be in the moment no
and so it's it's not for the fainted
heart to do that but it's really
exciting
how does it work with dating
I mean it's a good Icebreaker
I probably can go in in two different
directions you know I've said to myself
if I meet someone who I feel a strong
connection with which has happened
during these five years
I'll just uh
I'll spend more time in that area and
just make it happen and so I was dating
someone for like a year and a half in
Mexico City and that's one of the
reasons why I've been in Mexico City for
so long and before that I was dating
someone in Los Angeles so I was spending
more time in Los Angeles but you know
I'd still want to we talked about this
before I still would like to have a
family one day and I don't plan to
you know Force anybody to have this
particular lifestyle I may end up just
having a more conventional lifestyle
once that happens I don't know but
um but I'm open to all possibilities
right now and I know that
the way they get there faster and more
efficiently is just to be in the moment
with all of it so that's my commitment
it's just okay what can I do in this
moment to stay in the next moment
and as long as I'm answering that
question honestly then everything else
is is uh is going to be sorted out just
like that traffic jam was saving me from
having that really bad start to my day
could you ever imagine yourself back in
a situation where you're like rebooting
the shine or a scenario in which you
know you're working with lots of
different people and there's a kind of
level of complexity and kind of
day-to-day interaction that you're
currently liberated from sure absolutely
you know for me it's really just
allowing the guidance to occur from
within and not judging it so much and
just moving in that direction just see
what happens I don't know but I'm open
to everything at this point I'm open to
everything and and I could theoretically
go from living in a backpack to living
in a mansion or living on a yacht I
don't know but if it feels right in the
moment I'm gonna go for it light on a
super yacht yeah why not people people
send me oh like look at these tiny
houses like I don't like freaking tiny
houses I don't live in some tiny house
you know I like space I like beautiful
spaces
and I just don't need to own it and
that's really the big thing that's
changed for me is I can live anywhere
but I don't feel the need to own the
things that I have around me you know
well I think there's a there's a
cultural movement that is a larger
manifestation of what you're
experiencing personally I think there's
lots of people with the kind of digital
Nomad
um capacity that you know is available
to many more people now that
there are lots of people who are living
a version of what you're talking about
and then at the same time like kind of
technologically and economically we're
moving more towards this model of like
not owning things and just having things
available to us when we need them like
to rent them or subscriptions Etc you
know everything from Uber to Postmates
and all the way down the line to the
point where at some point it might seem
lunacy for anybody to own a car when you
can kind of summon one to come and get
you and take you wherever you want
whenever you want like it doesn't make
sense so I think we're having a
Reckoning with ownership in general yeah
and you're just kind of deeper down that
rabbit hole then most right now but I
you know it wouldn't surprise me if 10
20 years from now
um how we think about all of this stuff
will be a greater reflection of your
experience than than mine and it's been
happening anyway you know like you
you're not you don't own your body
you're just renting it from a spiritual
perspective what is it I mean ownership
is a is a is a contract it's a piece of
paper yeah honestly it's a social
understanding yeah it's really not
anything more than that yeah and
eventually you won't be here anymore and
who knows what's going to happen through
the stuff after that so you know we
really own you don't really own anything
right that's the thing even your house
your house is not a house your house is
a storage room with some sentimental
items in it and I know that's a very
harsh way to look at it but we tend to
hold on to things so much so that when
we're away from those things we can't be
present where we are because we're too
busy thinking about you know what we
have left behind and you won't really
appreciate what presence can feel like
until you kind of shift your perspective
around that and understand that I don't
really own this I don't own my children
right they're absentient beings there's
complete humans and souls and all that
I'm responsible for raising them to a
certain point and then they go off into
the world and then you see them on
holidays and and vacations and they're
having their own experiences you don't
really own your car you know you may be
making a payment on it but eventually
you may go on to a new car and
sell the old car and now someone else is
driving the old car right and so
effectively you were renting the car
it's just whatever your payment
structure was what it was so that
happens with everything and you may move
houses and so you didn't you know you
had you have everything for a period of
time so but wherever you are is where
you are and if you're not fully there
then you're definitely missing something
about that experience that that you
would you would probably be able to
access otherwise if you weren't so
um locked in on you know these things
that you've left behind so that's what
I've noticed just not having a home
people ask me all the time do you miss
having a home
well wherever I am is my home
right now my home is with you you know
and then I'm staying at a friend's place
and that's my home and and I can be
fully present there because all the
stuff that I have is with me right there
you know and it's in this little Airbnb
that I'm renting in Mexico City it's an
Airbnb I don't own it
so I'm not thinking about what's
happening back back there and I think
it's a really it's a simple way in this
really beautiful way to live because it
just makes you more available to
whatever's happening in the moment what
uh has been a surprising
aspect of living out of the backpack
anything you didn't anticipate you
always feel like you have too much stuff
[Laughter]
once you start scaling down you're like
oh my God okay I'm I'm only wearing one
of them we need this pen yeah do I
really need anything exactly oh my God
no yeah I mean again I started with the
carry-on bag and then I realized I had
too much stuff so I went to the
medium-sized backpack I still realized I
had too much stuff then I'm at the day
pack
and I still feel like I have too much
stuff and I still over Pack A lot of
times I like I'm over packing right now
because I do leave some things in my
Airbnb in the closet you know I'll leave
like an extra t-shirt or something like
that but
um
just to realize you don't need as much
as you think you need
and if you know how to like wash your
clothes and if you know how to you know
I've been very intentional about the
things that I pack so everything kind of
matches I don't have any like you know
floral patterns everything is kind of
soft right color yeah yeah so it all
kind of you got your like this is my
sort of uniform my capsules what I'm
gonna yeah the capsule right that's what
I wear I have a kind of joke around that
you know there is a bit of a it's a
fashionable trend on some level
particularly with dudes I don't see a
lot of women talking about this but like
you know I this is what I wear and it
removes all this decision fatigue I
don't have to think about what I'm gonna
wear because this is what I put on
like is that really true or I think
there's a lot of guys that just are
scared about fashion or don't know
themselves well enough yeah and that's a
very convenient kind of fashionable
thing to say to hide behind the fact
that they're just insecure about how to
dress and so you can say that and you
sound like a Savvy Tech bro but I'm not
sure it's always actually true yeah in
your case it is this is the capsule that
you but I spent you're living it I spent
a lot of time which I was at the mall
yesterday you're a former male model you
know fashion I was at the mall yesterday
for like three hours finding one pair of
pants yes and I tried on probably 20
pairs of pants because because whatever
only allow yourself one pair in that
backpack right so we better be right I
replace exactly and I and my standard is
I have to love this item of clothing if
I don't love it if I just kind of like
it I don't get it but if I love it and I
love the way it fits and I love the way
it feels and I love the way it looks
then I know that it meets the standards
and I can get that and then I'll re I'll
get rid of something else from the from
the backpack but then that article of
clothing will stay with me for however
long it lasts and then I'll replace it
again and so as you figure it out yeah I
did it with the pants I'm wearing now oh
yeah I was surprised because they're
light I would think you'd you'd prefer a
dark color because you didn't really
have to wash it as much it won't show
the stain yeah I generally do I
generally do but these probably will
only be with me for maybe you know six
months or maybe a year because I wear
them all the time so unfortunately when
you wear things all the time they kind
of wear down a lot faster but uh you
know you just recycle things I give them
away and or donate them and then I'll
I'll get another pair and you know so
it's it's it's just
I don't maybe I'll have a pair of pink
pants like I don't know this is just
these are the ones that yeah hit me at
the mall that's your beige the pants
you're wearing right now are the only
pair of pants you own
so I still have the pair that I replaced
with but when I leave Los Angeles you'll
leave those I'm gonna leave those yeah
oh that's sort of like a little
that's like a little cheat there's a
little overlap yeah yeah you're allowing
your because you're because I have to
try it I have to try it I have to see if
it passes that's the ration so I need to
wear it for a few days first okay
because you don't know just from trying
it on a dressing room you know but if it
passes all the tests
everybody's going to want to know what
brand uh we you know we can't do that
right
I'm not being paid by these people the
other thing that was amazing is no
laptop no laptop so this book
you wrote on your phone and on yeah
probably a tablet like this yes with a
little external keyboard to it exactly
yeah guy rated laptop in 2019. and again
it's a big decision hop of face four
years no no am I gonna be able to do it
and you surprising yeah I actually
considered just writing it on my phone
just for the story but I was like I
don't I'm not going to be that crazy
about it and doing the podcast where you
have to kind of deal with larger files
and stuff like that you were still able
to do it on a tablet yeah all my
podcasts has been done on a tablet so
again it's just you know you have to be
creative obviously and you have to work
out solutions that you probably wouldn't
even think about if you weren't doing
all of that but yeah it's surprising how
much you can get done
with less and um and again it's just I
just feel I resonate with that challenge
so that's why I did it I'm not saying
anybody else should do it like that but
um but at the same time you I'm
encouraging people not to use a lack of
something as a reason not to do
something there's always a solution if
you're looking for it and and if
anything that's the overarching message
is to find the solution with whatever
resources you have and and then
eventually you can pop you can you know
expand upon that and end up in a studio
like you were in that you started off in
that warehouse in Hawaii and now here we
are in this beautiful Studio you know in
Los Angeles
and um
maybe you didn't Envision the road from
there to here no but it it definitely
was a conscious decision to indulge my
curiosity yeah and that was a curiosity
that had been percolating for a long
time until I finally took some action on
it and there was that echo in the
warehouse that was terrible it was
terrible it didn't matter but you had I
didn't care because yeah so I just did
it for the fun of doing it to have the
experience of what it would be like to
try that the Curiosity my assumption was
that it would be terrible and I'd never
do another one again and I thought that
was fun
and I never thought twice about whether
it was good or not it was like oh that
was cool maybe we'll let's do that again
tomorrow let's see what happens
yeah same with me I started my podcast
in 2020 the sound quality was so
horrible that I almost considered not
releasing it because it just wasn't
perfect and you know now it's I you know
I'm nearly 200 episodes in and I it's
laughable to think that I almost didn't
release it because of the sound quality
that's just it is what it is that's how
I learned how to have better sound how
to get better mic and how to do all the
things better yeah you have to allow
yourself that that like lenius leniency
right
um and I like how in the book you talk
about the podcast and you know what
you've learned over the course of having
200 or so conversations and how you you
know kind of much like myself I mean
people ask me all the time like what's
your podcast about and it's it's hard
because I cast a wide net and talked to
a lot lots of different kinds of people
but but there is an overarching theme
which orients around transformation like
how do people change or how do they go
from where they were to where they are
what was that process like and I spent a
lot of time thinking about that and and
what I can extract from all of those
conversations and people that I've
talked to that would be helpful to other
people but you kind of did this very
thing and came up with a couple wisdom
pearls so talk a little bit about that
so in that part of the book I'm talking
about the
um
the row I call it the Rosa Parks moment
so for those of you who don't know Rosa
Parks was known as the quote mother of
the civil rights movement and she was
the one who stayed on the breast seat
and got arrested and then uh that
started the Montgomery Alabama bus
boycott which essentially kicked off the
modern day Civil Rights Movement
and people imagine Rosa Parks as this
kind of like elderly person you know who
was too tired to stand up but
actually Rosa Parks was only 42 years
old so she was eight years younger than
me at that moment in time and she said
it wasn't that I was tired too tired to
stand up she thought I was tired of
sitting down I was tired of giving in I
was tired of of adhering to these laws
that didn't make any sense this whole
thing about color writers had to ride in
the back of the bus so that white
writers could ride in the front of the
bus and that's why she stayed in her
seat
and you know
what's interesting about her story
Rosa Parks was a seamstress she was
coming home from work working as a
seamstress all day long now nobody would
look at someone who's a seamstress and
say that person's living their life
purpose
you know that that's that's their
calling in life because we tend to
associate
occupation with calling and oh I should
be a NBA player I should be a movie star
I should be a singer I should be a CEO
or a tech founder or whatever and the
whole point of that story is to say that
it's not about what you do
that determines whether or not you're on
your purpose
it's about how you are how you're
showing up to those moments and so your
Rosa Parks moment
could be the moment you went you know
you said enough is enough with alcohol
or someone else's Rosa Parks moment
could be saying enough is enough in this
toxic relationship I'm going to do
something different I don't know what's
going to happen I'm going to take this
hop of faith and it's scary and you know
she didn't know what the hell was going
to happen to her when she stayed in that
seat she could have been lynched
anything could have happened right but
it just so happened to kick off this
movement that made this 26 year old
preacher Martin Luther King Jr this
International you know celebrity and
giving one of the most popular speeches
in American history I have a dream
and so on the podcast
you know my podcast is about people who
found their purpose and people who have
created platforms to help the world
become a better place you've been a
guest on the podcast and so I take
people through basically a retrospective
of their life and everyone without
exception gets to their Rosa Parks
moment and that's usually what everybody
wants to hear about in podcast
conversations you know the whole thing
is just to build up to that moment
because that's what's most interesting
about your journey so if you're in
misery right now and you're thinking of
making a change that change becomes your
Rosa Parks moment but the misery that
you're experiencing prior to that
when people do interviews with you later
on that's what they're going to want to
hear about so I tell people you know pay
attention if you're going through misery
right now pay attention to everything
write it down if you can try to remember
as many details as possible because
that's going to become the good part of
your story right later on once you
follow your heart yeah I mean I think
that that um
that another way of looking at it is
instead of couching it as misery
you're out of alignment yeah right and
and the universe is kind of knocking and
they're saying
hey buddy how's it going over there feel
good you feel you sure you feel good
like you think this is okay cool check
in with you later and the longer you
kind of stay out of alignment or refuse
to kind of heed that that that heart
voice that thing that's trying to bring
you back into alignment the louder those
knocks occur the more suffering results
the more chaos you kind of reap in your
life until you reach an inflection point
you know my case like I've had a couple
of them you know getting sober was
certainly one and they're a function of
being in extreme pain and that pain
being a reflection of the extent of of
the disalignment right and I Wonder has
anybody asked Rosa Parks had anybody
asked her like right before she got on
the bus did she know she was going to do
that or would she have just said I know
she had no idea just happened in the
moment it's happened in the moment right
so but I'm sure there are like baby hop
you know little things that we're
building to her taking that action where
it just became the final straw yeah she
said the news about Emmett Till the
little 14 year old boy black boy from
Chicago who had gotten lynched sure
three white men that had just been in
the media and so she saw the open casket
yeah the open Castle funeral she saw
that and she was just like I can't I
can't participate in this anymore right
yeah but it also is not considered a
positive thing right right but if
something is feeling if it's resonating
with your heart it's again it's not
going to make you more comfortable it's
going to probably require a degree of
boldness
to be able to stand up right the but the
the
pain of staying in that place is
outweighed by the fear of taking that
bold action right or stepping into that
unknown or taking that leap of faith
yeah and it needs to be like you said it
needs to be a lifestyle can't be
something that you're just doing every
now and again because it's going to be
too scary to just wait until the big
leap of faith so you have to start
cultivating your ability to do that with
the small things and that's why I'm
saying
whatever the the heart voice is saying
to you if it's just take the stairs you
know um chill out read a book
um text your friend hey I miss you or
whatever the little thing is start start
getting into the into the habit of
acting on those little things and then
when you're Rosa Parks moment comes
you'll be much better prepared to stand
up and and face the pushback that you're
inevitably gonna have to face from
society or from whoever you're you're
standing up against yeah and what I
gather from the way you talk and write
about it is
is in doing that you can avoid or
sidestep some of that pain like I've
made these changes because I was in
extreme pain and it's probably familiar
for a lot of people but if you're
heeding that voice earlier on that says
you're out of alignment and you are
exercising
um those those baby Hops and kind of uh
practicing being out of your comfort
zone then those larger inflection points
are more a function of curiosity than
they are of being in pain so it's a
different choice that you can make or or
a setup that you can practice right it's
a difference in drama and adventure
there's no neutral path either you're
setting yourself up for some life drama
which is where you're resisting
resisting resisting
those hops or you can get ahead of it
and it's uncertain so that's what
creates the adventure of it but you're
in you're ahead of it so it's like
you're in control instead of waiting for
your whole life to like implode right
before you paid yeah yeah exactly losing
all your friends and losing all your
family and all that that's one way to do
it that's an adventure too it's an
adventure too and a different different
things and then it makes for you know
good podcasts right yeah yeah we love a
good comeback some people don't come
back no that kind of stuff well maybe
they come back in the next lifetime
that's true
um I didn't know you told a story in the
book about
um your friend will the yeah the teacher
and you know close friend of yours and I
was sad to hear you met him right when
you went to Tom's when you you went to
his apartment to when you met Tom
Knowles that yeah but there were a bunch
of people oh that was Will's apartment
in West Hollywood Laurel Avenue yeah I
was in his apartment that was his
apartment I didn't I didn't know that
yeah
um and I only knew a few people that
were there yeah um oh that's wild yeah
so he got Dengue Fever you got Dengue
Fever yeah and he had an adverse
reaction to it that caused him to go
into psychology
and what's interesting about that is
that he was one of the most grateful
people and most optimistic people that I
knew prior to that experience
so again it's one of those things about
life you just never know where which way
things are going in and
and you know he was living in Bali at
the time this is my friend who
introduced me to my meditation teacher
and I have to give him credit for really
me being here having the conversation
with you because if it wasn't for my
interaction with him
I don't know where I'd be but that he
played a pivotal role
and
um introduced me to everything that I'm
doing now and supporting me along that
process so yeah he ended up
taking his life as a result of the
psychosis that he was experiencing in
the depression that he was experiencing
after taking the medication for the
Dengue Fever that he contracted while
living in Bali
that is terrifying yeah
so was it the medication or was it the
we don't know because they didn't do it
on his family elected not to do an
autopsy so no one really knows it's all
just speculation and Theory at this
point I have a friend who contracted
Dengue fever and Bali I don't know two
years ago or something like that and it
was the the kind of um recovery from
that was significant but he luckily
didn't have any of that kind of
symptomology that's really scary yeah
and you know I think the point of that
story or that part of the story
was just that you know it's all not it's
not all roses and you know rainbows yeah
when you're when you're on your path and
when people are there to support you for
a reason a season or a lifetime and um
and secondly you know that's caused me
to start
having my experiences not just for me
and me being on my purpose but knowing
that you know someone else who wasn't
able to make it you know I'm I'm now
thinking about him when I go working out
and I go you know doing the things that
I do to kind of move this this purpose
forward and it's like I'm I'm living for
two people you know and and that gives
even more more weight to the things that
I'm doing and why I do them and he's one
of the ones that inspired me to actually
become nomadic as well he had gone
nomadic a year before me wow
if you have to articulate that purpose
how do you explain it I would say just
to keep it really really simple leave
the world more inspired
so leave situations more inspired
is is minimal and it's words yeah yeah
but you know I say your purpose is your
best editor too
so if you're clear about that and
everybody's not clear about it but if
you follow your curiosity long enough
your purpose will find you and then it
will start to become clearer and clearer
that oh when I behave in this way is
when I say yes to these types of
opportunities I feel that sense of
expansion so that must be you know my
purpose it feels aligned so now you have
your your greatest editor in life
because that is
that is the measuring stick by which you
decide okay this is for me this is not
for me this relationship is for me this
one is not for me because it aligns with
my purpose it allows me to be more of
who that person is but it's a bit of a
chicken and an egg though right I mean
you can't you if you know your purpose
then you can run that test so you have
to follow your character to find your
yeah like you kind of have to be doing
that already in order to yes you have to
split test it first but look it may take
you five years to split test it guess
what five years is going to go by anyway
so you may as well be intentional about
sourcing that because once you do that
you you experience the level of Freedom
that you wouldn't have otherwise yeah
when you think about a difficult day a
difficult day is difficult because it's
hard to make decisions right it's not
because something quotes bad happened to
you so it's like you don't know which
way you're going to go that's what makes
life difficult and you can be in the
same circumstance and it's really clear
and it's very easy to say this is the
decision vision for me is there's
freedom to that because you're being
emancipated from your fears that are
otherwise paralyzing You by analysis
I'd be careful to be too reductionist
about it or or binary about it like the
the scenarios I Envision like you have
you have the hell yes those are easy on
some level even the scary yeses are easy
because you know deep down this is what
you should do even though you're
intimidated to do it where it gets
tricky and murky and difficult is when
you have important values that are in
conflict with each other like you're
facing a decision and this thing is
important to you but also this thing is
important to you and they're both like
pretty core but whatever decision you
make is going to either prioritize one
over over the other or put them in
conflict with each other and that's
where I think a lot of myself like
that's where I run into a lot of issues
and then
I don't know if you can split you can
split test it but maybe it's a really
big decision like is this something
you're gonna run a test on you know it's
like what you know your example I
remember from our interview when I
interviewed you and you were your whole
life was crashing financially
and you were thinking of going back to
practicing law
and
Julie was saying you know you can't go
backwards you have to go forward and you
didn't know what that looked like right
so those are two very
um those are those are hard choices to
make you know do I do I go back to I
know what I know is a sure thing I can
definitely make you know x amount of
dollars doing this sure it's not my
passion or anything like that but I'm
good at it and I know I can do it and I
have a family and I have you know things
that I need to pay for and it's a
responsible thing to do yeah versus do I
take this leap of faith and you know
you're right those are not easy
decisions to make
and at the same time there is you know a
direction that may feel again more
aligned with your vision for yourself
and so what I'm suggesting through this
work is while those decisions are both
you know
they seem very well the the going back
to going backwards seems like the most
practical most responsible choice
we want to and and and following this
other path that's unproven seems like
the irresponsible choice on the surface
that we want to give more weight to the
thing that feels aligned without really
thinking of it in terms of practical
versus you know irresponsible and I know
that's a hard thing to do in the moment
but that's why it requires practice it
requires practice because you don't want
to wait until you're in that position
because you were going to default to
doing the Practical thing 99 times out
of 100. in your case you had someone you
had an angel there you know who's
backing up your heart voice saying no
you can't go backwards and you got lucky
in that situation
right five percent my argument is that
you probably
there were probably some other choices
you could have made prior to that that
would have even made it more convincing
to move in the direction of whatever
forwards was for you in your life I
think it's a little of both I mean I was
making smaller versions of those
decisions and and that had got me into
that situation to begin with I wouldn't
have been there had I not already been
you know kind of chopping it up along
the way
um but to your point yeah it was both
because I was in fear and in lack and in
doubt
and it would have been easy
to Pivot back and it required a lot of
Courage that I wasn't sure I had the
capacity for to keep going forward but I
did have the support
um and short of that I don't know that I
would have made that decision yeah in
fact I'm sure I wouldn't have
um but it's that idea of doing
the small little sets of push-ups every
day so that when you get to that big
decision there's a there's a level of
self-understanding and
courage or sort of conviction because
you have split tested it and you kind of
know that there's value in trusting your
your your intuition at that point
yeah and from a spiritual perspective
um you know
the idea of something that is
predictable
is actually the riskiest direction to go
in and the unknown that feels aligned is
actually the safest direction to go in
that's just the spiritual perspective on
that so if you go to some Guru somewhere
and you're like should I take the the
job that I'm good at or should I do the
thing that I really want to do they're
always going to tell you to do the thing
that you want to do and it's not to make
more money it's not to be successful
it's not to be you know receive rewards
it's creates that alignment it's to do
what feels aligned because you're there
to to serve in some way it's always
comes back to service and when you think
of it in those terms that's another way
to sort of figure out can I serve better
in this capacity or can I serve better
in that capacity
and whichever one is the one that's most
aligned with the service goal that's
going to be the one you get the most
support from you know the quotes the
universe if you want to call it where
you get those traffic jams holding you
up so that you're safe and you get those
you know inclinations to go get a
Rubik's Cube and you get the nudge to go
and offer the person Tire
changer you know Tire polish and it's
all in service too teaching more people
to meditate but it's not going to say
that there's no billboard saying this is
going to help you teach more people to
meditate it's just go through with this
and it's going to create this really
amazing experience that you're going to
share on a podcast one day and if you're
trying to answer those questions for
yourself or uh you want to go on your
own kind of Adventure in experimenting
with this
the other thing I think you would
probably recommend is that you go out
for a walk that you go flynoring right
had you heard of that before I never no
I had never heard of it you're getting
fancy so but I love this concept yeah
flynnuring is an 18th century French
term for aimless walking now off walking
is having a moment right now as well a
lot of people are walking first thing in
the morning this is a whole idea of 10
000 steps um and
what what I've been doing intentionally
especially since I got a smart watch a
few years ago is I've been tracking my
steps and then you know it becomes very
addictive to hit a certain number but in
the process
the whole thing with spiritual
minimalism is doing more with less so a
lot of people say oh you know I don't
have time to meditate I don't have time
to go out and see nature be in nature I
don't have time to get into the sun I
don't have time to do X Y and Z move my
body go exercise well with walking you
can do all of that
you can go out of your house
for a walk with maybe no object with no
destination in mind and then you're
practicing in real time split testing
the heart voice while you're having this
sort of meditative experience so you're
kind of going within you're making
choices from the inside out
and your heart is saying go in this
direction and again there's no throwaway
moments so you're treating everything as
if this is this is as special as some
profound conversation with your Mentor
with with Elon Musk or whoever you
admire Barack Obama and so go to the
left you go to the left and just see
what happens maybe nothing happens
that's obvious and then you know go in
the shop and get a iced coffee
maybe you don't even drink iced coffee
but so on the aimless walk because you
don't have a specific destination in
mind
you're getting a chance to do the split
testing you're getting a chance to
exercise you're getting a chance to do a
moving meditation you're getting it
giving yourself a chance to get some sun
exposure giving yourself a chance to
exercise you're doing all those things
and
and you're you're moving closer to your
path and your purpose and you're setting
yourself up for some potentially really
cool serendipitous moments so that's why
I'm a big advocate of of walking and
then there's all kinds of other you know
health effects digestion and you know
immunity and things like that get
stronger so right but beyond that like
setting that aside just this notion of
lenoring like walking for the sole
purpose of of walking and wandering
without
um
you know a directed intention to it and
ideally by yourself isn't meditation but
it is an active form of engaging with
your environment voice yeah and your
external environment
but you know not walking under the
influence of anything ideally because
that makes you less present
and not uh
not walking with someone else obviously
in a safe environment right but yeah so
that you're just absolutely present to
whatever you're experiencing and so that
that is a way that anyone can do to
check all of those boxes and so that's
that's one thing I talk about walking I
talk about abstaining from alcohol for
three months even if you're just a
casual drinker and it's not because I'm
anti-alcoholz because I'm pro-awareness
so if you want to strengthen that
connection with your hard voice
but you're drinking a glass of wine two
or three times a week that glass of wine
while you can easily justify it for
whatever reason
it's it's diminishing your connection
with your hard voice and if there's a
voice saying well it's just three
glasses of wine you don't know what
you're talking about
that's not your hard voice because your
hard voice would never tell you to do
something that diminishes the connection
to the heart voice so now you know for
certain that the dominant voice in your
head is not your heart voice so you need
to start split testing to get back to
that heart voice and that's why I
recommend abstaining for you know you
can do a month but doing three months
you really know okay there's not a
really big addiction situation here and
I haven't been drinking I haven't been a
drinker for
25 years or so it's not that I'm
completely sober every now and again
I'll maybe have a celebratory whatever
um but it's not something that I that I
that I that I do even on a mildly
consistent basis
um and I just feel like I'm fortunate in
that way because I've never really had
an addictive personality but I've had
long stretches of time years without
having anything to drink and again you
can't appreciate how strong that
connection is unless you give yourself a
meaningful amount of time yeah between
drinks I think beyond that also there is
a comfort with yourself that is
cultivated through the practices that
you're talking about that
puts you in a place where that idea of
of muting out
doesn't seem as desirable as it once did
because you don't have that that like
unconscious discomfort that
feels the Allure or the pull of the
substance that's going to kind of
um
just quiet all of that noise and I think
alcohol aside I mean alcohol is one is
is a substance but
if you don't drink I mean we all find
ways to distract ourselves or take
ourselves out of the present moment or
habits behaviors and other things that
um we use to not feel how we feel in the
current moment because we don't feel
good in ourselves and part of that is
being disconnected or out of alignment
and the more in alignment you become
then the quieter those impulses become
as well and I think
abstinence is a way of
creating Clarity around that because you
can really it's it becomes very kind of
like it becomes a very like tactile
experience yeah yeah it's it's in like
everything else we've been talking about
is a practice you know and it's you can
make that a meditation itself you know
what can I replace this with
um because I'm not advocating or when
you feel that pull or that discomfort to
just notice that yeah
yeah I think I I'm definitely a big fan
of the the tortoise approach as opposed
to the the hair approach and I think
that habits that are formed in tiny ways
end up being more sustainable than and
so in the book I'm not even saying go
three months in a row right off the bat
I'm saying go as long as you can go
until you work up to three months so it
may take you two years to get to three
months where you're you're getting a
drink every week once a week or
something like that and then you try to
go to two weeks and then you try to go
to four weeks and then you try to go to
eight weeks right and that may take you
six months but it's a fun way to kind of
be intentional about it where you're not
beating yourself up you're not shaming
yourself from having a drink you're just
challenging yourself in a fun way okay
how long can I go now can I can I
stretch it after three weeks and then
have a drink and then eventually you
make it to a point where you just you
don't desire to have a drink anymore or
you find it very difficult and then
that's powerful information yeah and
again this is so hard if you have a if
you have an addiction problem obviously
this is not the guide for that but this
is for people like me who are just kind
of saying whatever you discover as a
result of that is just information to
help you along the way yeah right yeah
um we gotta wrap it up here shortly but
what what is you know what do you how
would you articulate like the main idea
that you're trying to convey here or the
main kind of takeaway that you want the
reader of this book to
um you know Ponder when their head hits
the pillow the main takeaway is that you
have everything you need
to create the life that you ultimately
want right now
is that that you need more than what you
have if anything it's you need less less
distraction you need less uh temptation
to to use coping mechanisms and things
like that you need less stuff to buy in
order to be fulfilled or happy and so if
you go inside and you start with
cultivating the voice of your inner
guidance and you start listening to that
voice and you start acting upon that
voice that will take you in the
direction of whatever it is that you
envision for yourself you're not
expected to know how it happens
you just
make yourself as loyal as possible to
those little impulses
without any expectation or anticipation
of a specific result and eventually you
will live your way into that life of
your dreams which is going to come with
lots of challenges it's going to come
with you being stretched out of your
comfort zone and into your potential and
you will look back at those experiences
as the highlights of your life and those
challenging times as again the good
parts of your story that's what people
are going to want to talk about
and it's a real time
um
process
so it's about really being process
oriented as opposed to outcome oriented
you just recounted the story of my life
you know right you did it with you know
like
you know me trying to like how do I
explain this
um and you just did it beautifully like
concisely
because that's exactly how I think about
it and how
it felt and again it doesn't
it wasn't easy it's still not easy it's
not about that it's hard man
um but there is
there are like these
immutable spiritual laws
that time and time again I'm shown to be
true
all of which you you know speak about
here so I love it man yeah and to the
point of
abundance like the abundance that's
driving us or the desire for abundance
we're seeking it outside of ourselves
and and yet
it's within us and available to us all
the time right you have that quote about
the abundance that we don't create
abundance right that the abundance is
already there and we either create
access to it or limitations to it right
yeah yeah and uh you know I think back
to your book that you wrote the first
one
uh Finding Ultra and
you getting into the accident and
and you wanting to quit you know the
ultra marathon and running into the lady
and all this stuff and it's like those
maybe not be your proudest moments but
those are the ones that you know make
you you and everybody has their version
of that but you have to get out of your
your zone of comfort in order to to sort
of rise to that level of your potential
and I'm hoping that this book
helps people find that within themselves
with the understanding that it's not
going to be easy you know running an
ultra marathon is probably one of the
hardest things a human can do finish as
hard as the sin this sin this inside
stuff's harder than that I'm telling you
I'm telling you
um but you did an amazing job I love the
book I love the illustrations too thanks
man
um I work with this really wonderful
illustrator out of Germany and uh I've
been obsessed with the color blue for a
long time so I knew I wanted to have it
that's the galley copy so it looks all
black and white but it's really good I
have the digital one too yeah yeah and
it's and it's what I like about this
particular book kind of like my last
book is that it's it's actually created
in the way that I personally like to
experience books which is you know
anybody who gets a book the first thing
they do is they crack it open in the
middle somewhere and they kind of flip
through it and they see if anything
catches their eye and so this book is
actually written not to be read from
cover to cover but to be cracked open
anywhere and then whatever catches your
eye you read that section in each
section is only a page or two long and
then it can direct you to other sections
so it's kind of like a Choose Your Own
Adventure read it'll say if you want to
learn more about
capsule wardrobes go to this page if you
want to learn more about meditating you
know go to this section and and that way
people can kind of have their own little
experience with the book that's
different from anyone else's which again
is encouraging you to listen to your
hard voice your hard voice is saying
stop on this page and read it or read it
from cover to cover you get an
opportunity to practice that there you
go well beautifully rendered I think
it's going to help a lot of people I
think it's your best book yet and uh
super fun to talk to you about it today
always good to see you my friend yeah
this is honor man honor and a pleasure
being here with you 100
um right back at you and uh yeah you're
welcome back anytime beautiful I'm gonna
take you up on that cool man thanks dude
thank you again soon cheers peace
namaste